what's going on guys this is Rob and God
the ending of this is probably going to
be one of the most important things that
I think Marvel has been doing recently
in Marvel Comics so much so that like we
literally just kind of have to cover
this as a One-Shot origin so this takes
place in Immortal X-Men and it basically
builds and expands on the origin of Mr
Sinister from Marvel Comics going into
the sins of sinister's storyline which
will basically make the whole thing make
more sense so what this does here is
this initially opens up with Mystique
basically making her way into a military
base in New Mexico in 1943. now one of
the things to understand here and this
is what's really cool is that actually
makes her way through of course using
her powers and so on and so forth so
doing the different soldiers and so on
she ends up coming across Irene Adler
now one of the things to know is that
Irene Adler of course the mutant Destiny
she's a precog for those of you guys who
are not familiar with Irene Adler if you
know who she is bear with me here for a
second Destiny is a precognitive where
she can basically see the future the
further away she looks or the further
into the future she she looks the less
certain things are the closer she looks
into the future the more certain things
are but the thing that's going on here
and the reason why Irene Adler is even
here in the first place and Mystique is
meeting up with her is because this is a
laboratory or basically a facility where
Mr Sinister is working now one of the
things that I want to specify here is
that Sinister is a character with an
exceedingly long history in Marvel and
we'll talk about the existing origin for
his character as we get further into
this specifically the story from 1996
The Adventures of Cyclops and Gene but
the reason why this matters in terms of
it being in 1943 is because this is
where Sinister was operating at the time
that one of the things the Sinister had
done over the course of his existence is
he had become obsessed with the idea
that individuals were popping up around
the world that had powers right
basically mutants and so one of the
things that he had done during World War
II is he had experimented on people in
German camps the reason why that matters
is because following the end of the war
and the liberation of all those camps a
guy named true at Hudson had discovered
the journals of sinister and that's what
led to weapons plus right that's what
led to like Wolverine and Phantom X and
the stuff for Cuckoos and all those guys
right so a little cool bit of history
there when it comes to how the weapons
plus and weapons 2 through 10 programs
came into existence weapon one is
Captain America that actually was not
based on the works of sinister uh at
least not that I'm aware of because I
feel like the discovery of Truett Hudson
happened after Captain America was
frozen in ice so I don't know it's
Marvel doesn't really reconcile that too
well but the thing that Irene Adler says
and while her and and I'm sorry her and
Mystique have a very lengthy history
together Irene Adler says she's here and
she's quote unquote assisting Sinister
in experimenting on mutants because the
end result right the ends justify the
means like yes there's some pretty shady
stuff going on here right now but at the
end of the day what can be learned from
this and the greater consequence of what
Sinister is doing is more important than
the lives of the people who are being
sacrificed here at the moment and that's
one of those moral things that really
plays into the nature of Destiny City
oftentimes she'll let people be
sacrificed in the moment if it goes
towards something more important now a
person who can't see the future of
course cannot necessarily see the bigger
picture and the average person operates
in the Here and Now not being able to
see or even understand what role they
play in the greater landscape So to that
person being experimented on this is
begging the question why isn't anybody
helping me whereas Destiny looks at that
and says because quite literally your
life in the moment is basically
meaningless and your sacrifice here will
go to a much bigger thing but from here
there's really kind of a discussion
between the two of them in terms of
asking the question how did Sinister
survive his first first death in the
first place and so what we do is we jump
back to 1895 in London England and this
is when we really start to get into the
nature of sinister's origin though what
we actually end up having here in a
really really cool moment is we pick up
a 221 Baker Street or 221B Baker Street
anybody who knows anything about that
address knows that's the address of
Sherlock Holmes
now one of the funny things about this
and I love that Marvel's doing this
Sherlock Holmes does exist in Marvel
Comics he was in the old Marvel preview
issue number five back in 1976. he was
there for like one story nobody really
cared ultimately Marvel just kind of
Acts the existence of the character I
love that they're doing that by
basically saying it was Mystique
operating as as basically Sherlock
Holmes pretending to be him whether or
not it was like there is an actual
Sherlock Holmes and Mystique was
impersonating him or Marvel's simply
just saying there never was a Sherlock
Holmes and it's just an identity that
that Mystique is taking is really just
kind of you know up to interpretation to
be quite honest because even now they
don't necessarily clarify it too well
but what's cool is that the two of them
basically end up meeting up in order to
travel to Millbury house which is where
Sinister is operating out of at the
moment and in fact when they get there
they don't really meet Sinister they
meet Nathaniel Essex now here's the cool
thing about this and this is when we
really start to get into this origin
because what ends up happening here is
mystique and death Destiny have this
conversation with Essex where he says my
work on the Essex factors would be much
more advanced if I could be returned to
the years I wasted on fripperies like
love Nathaniel Essex wife died at some
point and so he really like looks back
on his life and says instead of getting
involved in things like love I could
have been working on my research right
like love prevented me from becoming
successful and focusing on more
important things as far as he's
concerned don't know I entirely agree
but nonetheless right what's really cool
here is that Irene Adler chimes in and
says Lord Darwin right this is the time
when Charles Darwin was still like the
top guy in the scientific Community she
says that that according to Darwin The
Works of sinister were basically a
monstrous misunderstanding of Darwin's
work himself and she fears that
basically she has to agree here that she
asked have you ever read Nietzsche your
talk of superior beings Echoes him his
work also ended in Madness it is not too
late to turn back now here's the reason
why this discussion matters here and
this is how we basically start to get
into the origin of sinister in the early
days of Nathaniel Essex when he was in
the scientific community and he was
obsessed with the idea that basically
mutants were popping up what he's
referring to as the Essex factor is the
x-gene inside of mutants that has not
been activated yet right remember the X
Gene and mutants activates either
through puberty or moments of high
duress or something like that but in
having no real name called The X Factor
he simply refers to it as the Essex
Factor he names it after himself is
really all it is but there came a point
when he created this really kind of
frankensteinian depiction of what those
individuals out there who are basically
mutants that have powers would look like
he built his work on the work of Charles
Darwin and saying that Charles Darwin
argues that Evolution Reigns Supreme
that individual organisms right birds
and bugs and animals and so on and so
forth that they all exist in these
different environments and ecosystems
and over time those environments and
ecosystems will change and that
Evolution will take hold of those
animals and they will evolve to
basically adapt in in that environment
what got him cast out of the scientific
Community was his depiction of the Essex
Gene and his depiction of what a future
mutant might look like which was
honestly very grotesque to the
scientific community at the time they
considered him to be a madman and they
ultimately forced him out and that's
where he that's why he's here now
because he's kind of an outcast of the
scientific community and is driven by
this desire to prove that he was right
and so the cool thing about this is that
them meeting with him really comes down
to this discussion that like he was
attacked by somebody he can't really
provide any details about it he didn't
really see what happened he just knows
that like he woke up and and somehow he
survived and you know he believes that
it was one of those meetings that exist
out there but following this this leads
to a kind of I guess detective a bit of
detective work by Mystique where she
takes on the guise of an innocent young
woman and starts making her way through
the city of London when she hears
somebody scream and when she gets there
she finds Sinister killing a guy and so
that's when literally she fires a shot
at him he realizes she can shapeshift so
she basically her existence verifies
that he's right that there are people
out there with powers right although it
was already kind of verified up to this
point he ultimately takes to the
rooftops and then runs back to his base
of operations when Irene Adler when
Destiny and Mystique catch up to him
they find him transforming from Sinister
back into Essex and that's when he comes
clean with the explanation now one of
the things to understand this is where
we kind of get really more broadly into
this origin really the the finer details
of this origin in Marvel Comics Sinister
of course Nathaniel Essex his obsession
with the mutant Gene the idea that there
are beings out there who have incredible
levels of power that was eventually
noticed by the villain apocalypse right
in Savannah that's who he's talking
about when he refers to as the Egyptian
who visited him and granted him Powers
the idea of sinister a really Nathaniel
Essex meeting apocalypse and explaining
apocalypse his belief system that those
individuals with powers are basically
the next step in human evolution that
was something apocalypse had never
considered before all apocalypse knew
was that he was just a being with
incredible power and used that to
effectively Force societies against each
other he had followed the old social
darwinist philosophy that was instilled
in him by ball and the sand Riders which
is only the strong deserve to survive
but when he met Sinister and sinister's
argument was there are people out there
with incredible power they can do
incredible things and they will lead the
world into arguably a better future
maybe not necessarily better but a
different future that apocalypse kind of
took that to heart and was like so
that's why I have the powers that I have
he almost saw it as a kind of like a
divine intervention right a Divine
Purpose for himself and this almost
religious zealotry merged with his
Viewpoint of survival of the fittest and
that's how we ended up with the version
of Apocalypse that we have today in
Marvel Comics but in order to ensure
because Nathaniel wanted to literally
spend all of time being able to explore
these genes and so on that apocalypse
basically told Nathaniel Essex he would
give him the means to do so now the
reality here is is that when apocalypse
shows up to you and says you know I can
give you a great gift it's like being
met by like like Pinhead in the
Hellraiser Universe right like the
cinebites like I mean sure right there
they have sites to show you and they can
take you to a new place of pleasure that
you can never imagine but it's a dark
and twisted version right it's literally
just pain and torment and so because of
that it's one of those things where the
gifts quote unquote of Apocalypse
oftentimes prove to be more of a curse
than anything else and so what you're
seeing here right now in terms of
Nathaniel Essex having this almost kind
of Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde's situation
where the Mr Sinister Persona is like
the evil one and Nathaniel Essex is the
good one it's basically the
quote-unquote gift of Apocalypse or him
gaining these Powers really overriding
him but what he's readily admitting here
is that the Sinister Persona is taking
hold he's moving beyond his ability to
control this version of himself that a
time is going to come when something's
going to happen and ultimately the
Sinister Persona is going to completely
and totally take hold more so than that
he literally argues that just by being a
scientist and being able to just look to
the Future and see what direction things
are going in these individuals popping
up right what he calls the Essex men or
basically mutants is really what that
means that where they're popping up you
know kind of here and there and it's a
smattering of appearances that by
whatever Manner and whatever means the
number of mutants in the world will
increase and what that's going to do is
set humanity and the mutant population
on a collision course they're going to
go to war with each other if for no
other reason than the fact that the rise
in mutants will represent the
elimination of humans and so what he
talks about is how he wants to survive
and see all of that but at the end of
the day it seems like it'll be
impossible that he's toying with the
idea that he will inevitably die and for
you know perhaps even take his own life
because of the fact that he doesn't want
to become Sinister and so what he says
is he set in motion a way to guarantee
his existence but because of the level
of insanity that he's putting out there
and because of the fact that according
to Destiny he represents a clear and
present danger that what ends up
happening is he's literally locked in an
insane asylum but where he starts
babbling on and he literally starts
saying like red and black and red and
black and just kind of talking to
himself constantly seeing a person
that's not there he refers to them as a
ghost and then he's ultimately destroyed
like he literally dies in the middle of
the night and so we're like I read I'm
sorry we're a Mystique pretending to be
Sherlock Holmes shows up here bribes a
guard and then realizes the guard is
corrupt killing them you know so that
there's no witnesses to anything in any
story they can be they can imagine can
be concocted here that what happens is
Irene Adler goes back to the to Mulberry
House and literally explores the
residents of Nathaniel Essex but she
puts on what is basically a recording of
Nathanael where he talks about these
different things and so he says Darwin
said I was wrong but I was never so
proud as to say the same to him his
Insight was profound this is what my
legacy will be this is how I will be
immortal and to see how the world will
play out this is how we'll win the war
against humanity when they try to
destroy the mutant population Charles
Darwin was right in the end there is
only one way to find a solution to my
predicament survival of the fittest and
so what we end up finding out here is
that there are four canisters down in
the basement of sinister and what he had
done is he had cloned himself four times
then each one basically has a playing
card on his head this is why this is so
important because in Jerry Dugan's X-Men
Volume 2 the stasis storyline we saw a
version of sinister that had a clover on
his head he didn't have a diamond and so
that version was literally like I
haven't like I'm the only Sinister I've
always been Sinister I don't know what
other version of sinister you're talking
about there's also one with a spade
there's one with a heart and there's one
with a diamond and so what this means
and what mom was telling us is every
instance where we've seen Mr Sinister in
Marvel from this point in time in 1895
running all the way up until now it's
only been one of the four sinisters
there have been four others out there
they are three others out there and
they've just been doing their thing
we've never seen them or seemingly never
seen them and they don't know about each
other or if they do they're certainly
not revealing it but like none of like
all of them believes they're the actual
Sinister so if they did happen to come
across another or if they became aware
of another they would consider to be
some inferior clone and would probably
disregarded they wouldn't really care
about it at all but basically it's
amazing because no version of sinister
that we've seen up to this point is the
actual Nathaniel Essex that guy's been
dead for a couple hundred years he's
been gone for a long time and all we've
seen are clones running around so let me
know what you guys think about this new
origin for his character thank you guys
for watching and I will catch you on
later peace